-Our next guest is a five-time
Grammy-winning singer,
songwriter, and producer.
He's the front man for the ban
Bleachers, whose new album
"Take the Sadness
out of Saturday Night,"
is out July 13th.
Please welcome back
to the show --
Sorry, July 30th.
I was going to say.
Wait, right?
We've got it now, Wally.
Not in the past, you guys,
it's coming out in the future.
[ Laughter ]
Please welcome back to the sho
Jack Antonoff.
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Hi, buddy.
Yeah!
-Hey, guys.
How are you?
-So happy to have you here
and I'm so happy you've go
our complimentary mug.
-I love it.
-It's really nice, right?
-Yeah, it's great.
-We've scaled down a little bi
from the ol--
-When you come to the show
you get this.
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-And you take it home.
-That's wonderful!
-And it sucks.
-I want to thank you.
You've done double duty
for us this week.
You were here yesterday
with Lorde. you're here today.
You're going to play music
for us today.
And I know you've collaborated
with Lorde for a while.
We talked about you yesterday,
but I did not realize this -
that your parents are now
friends with Lorde's parents
-Yeah, they're like they hang.
-Is that cool for you?
-Well, I think they party
a little bit, but --
actually don't know about --
I'll segue.
My parents party
-Okay.
hard and I've noticed
that they like --
Yeah, our parents are cool
They do stuff,
but I don't want to out anyone
else's parents for partying.
The older I've gotten,
like every stage
that I go through in life,
my parents start doing
different drugs.
-Really?!
-Yeah. Because they're
like letting go.
-So they were on the straigh
and narrow when you were young
-Yeah.
-Is that what you're saying?
-And I think like
then, when I kind of moved out
which was a little late,
got my own place,
like where my dad got real
into pot
and, now, he's just like -
I mean, if we get back on tour
hopefully, this will happen,
but, in the past, sort of like
floating around the shows
with like a [bleep] joint
in his mouth,
[ Laughter ]
like just real --
-Is he sort of publicly
known by --
I mean, he must be known
at least by your sort of -
-Yeah.
-"That's your dad."
-He shows up
and he plays with us
and he's just a character
and kind of just like,
you know, if I meet, you know,
kids after the show,
like by the bus or something
they'll be like,
"Great job, blah blah.
Saw your dad and he was real
high and he was, you know...
[ Laughter ]
...telling me something
about the Kennedy assassinatio
that was really interesting,
but not one of the theorie
I've ever heard," like.
So I just think he like,
you know,
he's like he likes to party.
And I think it's cool,
but there has been like this
you know, the more I don't see
to need them to look after me...
-Yeah. That did not happen
with my parents.
My in-laws
are like that, though.
-Okay, yeah.
-Yeah, they're
definitely like --
-Your parents don't get high
-My parents don't get high
-They get drunk?
My mom has been known
to have a cocktail.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
They have been known to see it
-I feel like,
because there's no audience,
there's just your friends...
-Yeah.
-...I feel like
they have context
and some of the things you'r
saying are going to land harder.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-Right?
-It's deeply unfair.
-I'm assuming you guys
all know his mom.
-Yeah.
-Okay, so it lands.
-Well, look, based on everything
you've said so far,
they want to know your dad
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
My dad would be here
and would be like,
"Hey, like it's a --
Camera's great.
Like, um, I, uh --
Wanna get high?"
[ Laughter ]
"Camera's great."
-Yeah. And he also says like
really, he's a master of lik
saying something rude
that's a compliment.
"Like Seth, you were
actually really funny.
You were actually --
Yes.
No, it's like a really
incredible show."
[ Laughter ]
Like.
-Yeah. Like, "I did not know
when I came here --
I came here
to see my son Jack.
I had no expectations of you
and you were really funny.
-His favorite bit --
"I don't know why everyone say
you're such an ass[bleep].
[ Laughter ]
He loves saying that.
Nice!
-Is he deeply proud of you
-Well, they get --
One thing I notice about parents
within what I do is
there's so much mythology
that you see in film and T
about music and I'm sure
you have it with your work
and it's such a different
actual lifestyle.
But for them, they just ge
to dive into the mythology
-Right.
-It's just joints.
It's shows.
It's sweat.
Maybe they have sex sometimes.
I don't know.
But --
Guys, come on.
[ Laughter ]
-I should tell you something
about this group.
Once they think you need it,
they disappear.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I also feel like
they're like
I was here yesterday and -
-Yeah. You've already worn off
-Yeah, I feel like
they're like --
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, so I feel like
they get all those sides of it
and I'm way more kind of focused
on my work and --
-Yes.
You know, I'm going to do
a show in Boston
and, you know,
my parents are coming.
They're bringing
a lot of friends,
which is exciting
and it's a fun night for them,
but I will be --
they'll want to like get lunch
-Totally.
-or I will want to
be prepared.
-Get ready.
-Yeah, right, exactly.
And so it is an interestin
balance because --
But also, they're not
doing it maliciously.
They're just so excited.
-I love it.
I sort of love when some
of that stuff is around me
Like I don't even get high
but I love when people around me
are getting high, for example,
because I just love
the feeling of it,
like people being loose
and having a good time.
-Yeah.
-Sometimes that goes on
with my band,
where it's like they'll part
or something more than me.
And I just really enjoy
being around it
and it just makes me feel like
free through them or something
I can't enjoy it
too much myself.
-Yeah.
I know what you mean, though
It is nice to be
around people having fun.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know you super well.
I mean, we've been lucky enoug
to meet over the years,
but I was telling you backstag
you did a song
with Bruce Springsteen
this year.
-Yeah.
-And, even though, like,
you know, like I said,
I don't know you that well
I got goosebumps when I saw it
because I thought,
"Oh, this is such a cool thing."
Like just based
on what I know about you,
I thought,
"What a thing to be doing.
How did it come about
and was it as much fun to do
as it was to see?
-It was a blast.
Things like that always
happen pretty naturally
because you can't really
plan that stuff,
especially in artists like him
Very important -- him and Patt
are important people in my life,
as artists, as humans,
they're just as good as it gets.
But also to have, you know
he's an artist who
was the first person
where I heard the sounds of...
sort of my place.
I grew up listening
to the Beatles
and like sing every hook,
every little piece.
I grew up on my parents' music
and all this wonderful stuff
But when I started hearing
the music from New Jersey,
which, Bruce is, obviously
an architect of,
and then I got into a lot
of local music, I got into -
but it was just like,
"Oh, I know these landmark
and I know these feelings,
and it makes you feel
like there's a value there
a torch worth carrying,
and that's a funny thing,
from where I'm from,
because,
if you're from New York,
oh, that musical history
is beaten over your head.
If you're from London,
L.A., San Francisco,
it's like,
"Welcome to the party,"
you know, you were born
into this dynasty.
New Jersey is a little bit lik
this perpetual younger brother
and his work is given
a lot of us courage
to carry that sound and it's
a pretty specific sound.
A lot of darkness,
a lot of hope,
a lot of horns, a lot of joy
And it's --
I feel it so deeply.
So to have him on there wa
pretty circular and emotional.
-Do you find it to be
a contradiction
that I feel like
New Jersey musicians
are both deeply proud
of being from New Jersey
and write a lot of songs
about how badly they want
to get out of New Jersey?
-It's the culture.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I want to say
that your entire crew,
like between the past two days
I think I talked
about New Jersey
with every single one.
[ Laughter ]
Ocean County or...?
Monmouth or Ocean's over there
Talking about like
run of the mill,
like "How much more expensiv
can Long Beach Island get...
[ Laughter ]
...before nobody can go?!
Or before it's
the [bleep] Hamptons?"
Sorry.
Yeah, well, that's --
you know, you grow up
and you have this --
It's medieval, right?
There's New York City,
there's this body of water
You call it a moat.
New Jersey's right there.
The whole of New Jersey
hugs the city.
You're looking at it.
A lot of people,
kids grow up in New Jersey
and can see New York City
from their bedroom,
which is where
their favorite band
is probably playing that night
And not coming to New Jersey
It's where the food
and the culture
and all these things and the sex
and everything
is happening there.
But there's a cynicism to that
and I didn't grow up like that
A lot of the New Jersey musi
I love has a lot of hope
and it's maybe
about getting out,
but it's about reaching
for something
and it's just really ingrained
in how I see the world.
-I'm so happy, as always,
to talk to you
and I'm so happy you're sticking
around to do a song for us
-That's it?
-That's it.
-I had so many more things
to ask you about.
-Oh, really? You were goin
to ask me about stuff?
-I just feel like, last time
we started on this tradition
about talking about Judais
and I wanted to get back to it
-Yeah. Well, I can only say --
-You're like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
I think we're getting closer -
Next time, it'll be an even more
interesting conversation
because, you know, now,
I've got these two kids
who are, you know...
-They're Jews.
-...they're going to be Jews
-Yeah.
-I mean, they are Jews.
-and they think you're a Jew
-They do think I'm a Jew
and, one day, I'm going to hav
to sit them down and be like
"Got bad news
about two things --
Santa Claus and your dad."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And here's what they're
going to say --
"We didn't think you were a Je
because you're our dad.
We thought you were a Jew
because you look like Jew.
[ Laughter and applause ]